I once told a Fortune Magazine writer...
...that someday people like me would go to jail.
And that became the headline of a Fortune article.
They went on to describe me as America's greenest CEO.
From plunderer to recovering plunderer, to America's greenest CEO, in five years.
That frankly was a pretty sad commentary on American CEOs in 1999.
Asked later in the Canadian documentary, The Corporation, what I meant by the "go to jail" remark,...
...I offered that theft is a crime.
And theft of our children's future would someday be a crime.
But I realized for that to be true,...
...for theft of our children's future to be a crime,...
...there must be a clear demonstrable alternative...
...to the take - make - waste industrial system that so dominates our civilization,...
...and is the major culprit, stealing our children's future,...
...by digging up the earth and converting it to products that quickly become waste...
...in a landfill or an incinerator. In short, digging up the earth...
...and converting it to pollution.